as some ukrainians in sumi took a
one-way bus ride to safety in the dark
others cried from beneath rubble as
rescuers dug them out
by morning people woke up with mobile
phones in hand to take video of
smoldering apartment buildings outside
their windows
the ukrainian deputy prime minister says
the hope is that beginning at 9 a.m
local time on wednesday a ceasefire in
places such as the kiev kharkiv and sumi
regions would hold for 12 hours so
people could escape the fighting along
humanitarian corridors both ukraine and
russia have agreed to
novak
residents are asking me to make sure the
russian federation fulfills its promises
and people can leave the places they've
been hiding from the fire and the
shelling that is killing them
the spokesman with the russian ministry
of defense didn't address that during a
briefing
instead he spoke about a trove of
ukrainian military documents seized
during a special operation
he accused the ukrainian military nato
and the u.s of plotting an attack in the
donbass region in the east
the military operations by the russian
forces prevented the assault of the
ukrainian military on donetsk and
lohan's people's republic in march it's
unclear how deeply the united states and
nato were involved those who are so
worried about peace in ukraine
new allegations of war crimes have
emerged amnesty international says as
people lined up to get bred in a public
square in chernahiv last week it was hit
by multiple bombs three people were
killed amnesty says its investigation
shows at least eight so-called dumb
bombs rain down on the square and it's
likely a russian air strike the
international criminal court is now
investigating war crimes in ukraine
natasha
let's go to natasha butler who's in the
western city of lev she's there for us
live now
natasha talk us through firstly the
latest on efforts to evacuate civilians
from the hardest hit towns and cities
how's that going
well we have a bit more information now
because there was a lot of conflicting
information about the implementation of
these humanitarian corridors
a bit earlier what we do know is that
ukraine has agreed with russia to
evacuate people from at least
five towns and cities uh across ukraine
including uh areas around kiev and also
uh the northeastern town of sumi now
what we do know is that in terms of sumi
people have been leaving today the
cease-fire there seems to be holding
between ukrainian and russian troops and
people are being uh bust out this is the
second day that people have been able to
evacuate this city there are about a
quarter of a million people in the city
five thousand of them left on tuesday
many more will leave today and some of
the stories of people who are coming out
are just heartbreaking people having to
leave behind relatives who can't move
are not mobile enough to go other people
saying that they were effectively
running out of food out of water out of
medicine huddled in dark basements
whilst shelling was continuing through
the night very terrifying scenes but of
course for those people huge relief that
they are now able to leave they're going
we understand to an area in south of
sumi and then they will be moved on uh
elsewhere as they wish
but
what the one of the concerns of
ukrainian authorities is that they say
that uh in previous days russia has
offered to put ceasefires in place to
allow people to evacuate various cities
along these humanitarian corridors but
in fact fighting has continued ukrainian
forces ukrainian uh officials blaming
russians for not holding on to those
ceasefires or offering people safe
passage but to russia to belarus which
for ukrainian officials is absolutely
unacceptable uh they have called that
genocidal the idea that uh ukrainian
people would want to flee to russia when
russia has invaded their country
and natasha i understand that there's
some concern now being raised around the
safety of the chernobyl nuclear plant
which was taken over by russia
uh about two weeks ago what more can you
tell us about that
yes chernobyl the now defunct nuclear
plant that is near the
belarussian border there are there are
news reports coming out around that and
i just want to uh read you some of them
but ukraine's basically saying that
russia has effectively disconnected
chernobyl from the grid the ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky put out a
video and he's been tweeting about that
saying that the lack of power chernobyl
is now going to prevent the cooling of
spent nuclear fuel that could mean a
radio active risk also ukraine's state
power
agency says zielinski says that ongoing
fighting in the area is making it
absolutely impossible to carry out
repairs and restore power to chernobyl
we know also that um earlier today uh
nuclear monitors at the iaea said that
they had lost contact with some of the
ukrainian staff at chernobyl that some
of the staff there had already been
working extremely long hours around the
clock without rests without proper
breaks and there was a lot of concern
for them because in terms of safety and
security that's obviously not good now
they are saying they've lost contact
with some of those staff it is a huge
concern you know 1986 china was uh the
scene of the world's you know at that
time world's worst nuclear disaster
nobody wants to see a repeat of any
radioactive risk so
as i said some of that information just
coming out now will clarify more when we
get more in the day okay thank you for
that natasha butler there for us in lev
in the west of the country we can now go
to the capital city
uh kiev we can speak to our
correspondent steph vassen who's uh
who's there now i believe you are in a
bus shelter a bomb shelter just talk us
through the situation where you are
no i'm actually in a subway uh station
and if you go down from kiev in all
these subway stations
there's a whole world uh life has gone
underground basically so many people are
now living here for the last two weeks
they brought their children their whole
families are here they brought their
mattresses their blankets they're
sleeping here it's of course at night
very cold it's still winter here they
even have like a cinema for children
playing children's films and there's
also a clown who is entertaining the
children here right now she just told me
she normally works with
cancer patients in a children's hospital
but they all have been evacuated
to poland so now she's a grandmother
herself she came down here every day to
entertain the children because of course
being here for two weeks already they
have nothing to do they're in fear
because they're really worried about
what's going to happen next they think
they're safe here from the russian bombs
and missiles but of course
it's just a very relative safety and
there's also a train
so you can see this is a subway train
people were sleeping in that train also
for the last couple of days they've just
been told to exit that train because the
train is gonna move
uh they have to uh evacuate other people
so people took all their stuff out their
blankets and now they are waiting here
sitting here like this old woman she was
sleeping in the train
for the last couple of days she's
exhausted people are really exhausted
they're stressed out and they're really
in fear
absolutely incredible
what we're seeing
where you are two weeks stuck
underground like that families with
children
and talk us through
what we know about
the approach of russian troops towards
kiev because we know kiev is
strategically incredibly important to
putin president putin to win over
absolutely the people here are very much
aware that this is the main prize for
putin for the war that he's fighting
here in ukraine and there is fighting
going on on the outskirts of kiev and
it's increasingly heavy in the north
west there's been fighting for the last
couple of days
in ear pin there's a very strategic
bridge if that bridge falls into the
hands of russian forces the next stop
will be kiev and then in the northeast
this morning we heard very heavy
artillery fire in that area as well so
basically what you can see is that
russian forces are really closing in
from both sides trying to encircle the
city and there's a lot of worry that
even though maybe this advance onto the
capital has been stalled for nearly a
week that it's picking up and there
could be a really major assault on
kiev in the next coming days so
up off ground there's complete silence
emptiness people are really literally
holding their breath for what's coming
next and here on the ground people are
really hoping that they're going to be
surviving what's going to happen to them
okay many thanks for your reporting step
vassen uh speaking to us there from
underground at a train station
where many of the
people are
sheltering in ukraine
russia's foreign ministry spokeswoman
says moscow is not trying to overthrow
ukraine's government but she's indicated
some progress had been made in
negotiations
there are also negotiations with the
ukrainian side to try and avoid
bloodshed the third round of these talks
have finished political and humanitarian
issues were discussed the humanitarian
corridor was discussed about 2 million
people have now addressed russia with a
request for protection and 140 000
people have gone into russia
jabari has more from moscow
according to
the spokesperson for russia's foreign
ministry
they now have evidence which they found
from various locations in ukraine that
shows that their ukrainian government
was working on a biological program with
the help of the united states and this
is something that is very much a concern
for the russian government that they
want the united states to answer but the
spokeswoman also reiterated that
the
russian forces are not looking to
overthrow the government in kiev and
they're not looking to occupy ukrainian
land and that their mission is very much
one to try and get rid of the threat
that is perceived here by
the
ukrainian elements that are in that
country
the interesting thing was that she
didn't mention anything about the recent
sanctions that have been placed on
russia which is now the uh
number one country in the world with the
most sanctions against it as of uh
yesterday there is now over uh nearly 6
000 sanctions against the russian
government and different entities
overtaking iran which has just over 3600
sanctions against it